[Musique]
invités devaient y paie aujourd'hui
arnaud hermant bonjour bonjour bienvenue
en plateau vous êtes grand reporter pour
l'équipe en charge plus particulièrement
du football
votre nouvel ouvrage vient de sortir et
je le montre tout de suite comme ça on
le verra et on verra de quoi il s'agit
dans l'histoire du camp des loges aux
éditions braquage sport camp des loges
situe à saint germain en laye lieu
d'entraînement du psg mais pas seulement
c'est ce que nous allons voir tout à
l'heure nous allons parcourir ce livre
déjà tout d'abord un mot sur votre
carrière vous avez 45 ans vous êtes
grand reporter au service des sports
pour l'équipe vous occuper du football
pardon mais vous l'avez été aussi au
parisien
vous avez une passion c'est le psg déjà
pourquoi le psg
une passion en tous les cas c'est un
sujet que je traite depuis que j'ai
commencé
si elle est un peu pour le fuxéen 19 h
c'est un club que j'ai supporté dans ma
jeunesse a racheté abonné en tribune
auteuil et donc j'ai fait des
déplacements j'ai fait beaucoup de
matches dans les années 90 dont les
belles années canal+ et donc c'est un
club j'ai envie de dire un peu comme
tout à chacun comme tout jeune qui aime
le foot et il se rapproche ou en tous
les cas il se tourne vers vers son club
de région où son club 2 qui est le plus
proche de chez lui il ya un côté un peu
l'esprit de clocher et moi étang des
yvelines de maisons laffitte à l'origine
est maintenant à côté de versailles
c'était le paris saint germain qui était
en poste quand j'étais à
maisons-laffitte saint-germain maisons
laffitte les cinq minutes 5 10 minutes
donc j'allais aux entraînements j'allais
au camp des loges et c'est comme ça que
est née ma passion ou en tous les cas
mon mon attachement paris saint germain
et vous avez signé des ouvrages sur mba
paix serait vraiment vite c'est
également sur l'air qatar aussi vous
avez parlé de la belle école de canal
plus simplement la belle époque
aujourd'hui le psg c'est une très belle
époque pour le psg mais c'est totalement
un autre monde on a c'est un petit peu
déshumanisé on a basculé dans un autre
dans un autre registre vous êtes dans un
club qui a six ou sept cents salariés
même peut-être un peu plus qu'à 600
millions de budget voire plus qui est
vraiment rentré dans une autre dimension
dans une autre galaxie qui a pour
ambition d'être une des dix plus grandes
franchises de sport au monde a
simplement de football de sport au monde
nos salles bien être capable de
concurrencer ou en tous les cas être
dans le même panier que les los angeles
lakers que les dallas cowboys de
l'américain donc c'est vraiment
maintenant les partenariats avec par
exemple ses mots c'est une marque est
totalement mondiale qu on a basculé dans
totalement autre chose et pour les
journalistes est vrai que c'est pas
aussi simple ou en tous les cas c'est
pas du tout le même métier ou la même
approche que il ya dix quinze ans mais
le rapport a changé avec le club avec
les sportifs avec les fans aussi ah ben
je regardais un peu les différents
articles oui il pouvait un peu compliqué
mais moi j'ai beaucoup écrit sur les
supporters et notamment sur les ultras
j'ai beaucoup et
cris sur leur dérive parce que
évidemment ils font beaucoup de belles
choses notamment il anime les tribunes
et ils sont une composante du club mais
je pense que chacun doit rester à sa
place et ils ont tous renoncé à mon sens
je ne dis pas que j'ai raison et je ne
cherche pas à convaincre les gens mais
je pense qu'ils vont au-delà de ce
qu'ils doivent apporter au club sous
prétexte d'être un peu les garants de
l'histoire du club ce qui est une vérité
sont les garants mais s'il n'ya pas
d'actionnaire s'il n'y a pas ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de clubs
non plus il faut pas non plus se mentir
donc je pense qu'il ya eu des dérives
c'est quand même un club de football le
paris saint germain où des supporters du
même club se sont entretués faut pas
l'oublier même si c'est une autre époque
aussi
donc moi j'ai beaucoup écrit sur eux
j'ai je les ai critique et donc qu'ils
me veulent je pense à juste titre pour
de leur point de vue allez parlons du
camp des loges spécifiquement c'est
l'objet de cet ouvrage avant d'en faire
un livre vous l'avait fréquentée quand
vous étiez plus jeune nous l'avait bien
campés peu en tant que supporters ou en
tant qu'amateur de football
et puis après je les fréquente et comme
comme journaliste beaucoup puisque je
vous dis j'ai commencé à suivre le psg
en 2002-2003 et vous avez découvert de
nouvelles choses en faisant cet ouvrage
vous dire beaucoup de choses que vous
saviez y avait c'est en fait un endroit
qui m'étaient familiers parce que j'y ai
passé beaucoup beaucoup de temps
notamment il ya quelques années quand il
était davantage ouverts aux journalistes
qu'on pouvait venir voir les
entraînements je passais plusieurs
heures par jour là bas mais j'ai
découvert beaucoup beaucoup de choses
parce que c'est un endroit finalement
qui m'était familier mais que je ne
connaissais pas très bien notamment son
histoire son histoire ancienne et puis
tout ce que tout ce que ça représente
dans l'histoire du paris saint-germain
évidemment mais aussi du sport français
et du sport en général mais parce que ce
n'est pas uniquement le paris
saint-germain candela j'ai ça dans
l'esprit du grand public c'est pas
forcément assimilés aux péricard qui a
fait la préface et qui est à l'origine
du livre le maire nous a mis un terme en
laye tout à fait qu'il voulait un livre
dans le cadre des 50 ans du paris
saint-germain c'était un peu le prétexte
mais un livre un peu de témoins beau
livre un livre qui marque un peu aussi
le passage du club
quelques années avant son départ à
poissy puisque le paris saint germain va
déménager et l'objectif c'était de
montrer que le camp des loges est un
le choeur sportifs de la ville de saint
germain s'était pas que le psg même si
comme vous l'avez très bien lundi dans
l'esprit des gens quand on dit camp des
loges ans psg mais le camp des loges à
l'origine c'est un camp militaire et
c'est la zone sportive de saint germain
en laye quel autre sport on y retrouve
alors on y retrouve l'athlétisme le
rugby le hockey sur gazon puisque je
vais vous le savez c'est un club très
très fort en hockey sur gazon club de
saint germain et puis après ben vous
avez le tennis bien sûr pour tous les
sports qu'on retrouve dans une dans une
commune comme une lampe dallas et au
camp des loges au stade georges lefèvre
plusieurs joueurs présentent leurs
souvenirs aussi alors là pour le coup on
est plutôt du registre du psg dans votre
ouvrage gilbert ab haut la main motta
luis fernandez aussi elle est le
personnage le plus emblématique pour
vous le camp des loges est indissociable
de quelle figure
j'ai envie de vous dire luis fernandez
parce que luis fernandez c'est le trait
d'union dans le cas d'une paris saint
germain c'est le trait d'union c'est
tout les général cela il a fait toutes
les générations il a été formé dans les
années 70 il a démarré là il a joué
joueur mythique du club dans les années
80 associé au premier trophée de du
paris saint-germain les deux coupes de
france 82 83 le premier titre et puis
après entraîneur des années dans les
années 90 qui gagne la coupe des coupes
96 il revient comme entraîneur dans les
années 2000 et il revient comme
dirigeant dans la deuxième partie des
années 2010 donc que oui luis fernandez
c'est clairement le trait d'union le
joueur un peu emblématique du paris
saint germain
et il raconte justement son camp des
loges dans cet ouvrage avec les autres
joueurs en plus du reportage que vous y
consacrez très large pour découvrir les
coulisses des anecdotes aussi c'est ce
qu'on découvre à travers ce livre il ya
peut-être une anecdote plus qu'une autre
qui vous a marqué moi en regardant un
petit peu je retiens celle de nicolas
anelka qui quitte le club en 97 c'est
mon nom du transfert pour arsenal c'est
son père qui viennent chercher loyer via
le chercher dans une aile encore loin du
de ce qu'on pouvait imaginer comme
football on va dire
payet ferrari et autres qui part dans
une peugeot 404 je crois de mémoire
voilà son papa vient le chercher il s'en
va nicolas anelka qui a fait une
carrière exceptionnelle et qui est un
enfant du paris saint-germain donc oui
c'est des petites anecdotes comme ça
mais il y en a plein d'autres parce que
le paris saint-germain cette qualité
d'être capable de renouveler son
actualité sans cesse positivement ou
négativement et dans les différentes
anecdotes laquelle vous vous a marqué le
plus bas moi ce qui me m'a semblé alors
ce que j'ai bien connu cette période
mais c'est un sujet récurrent l'histoire
du paris saint germain et du coeur des
loges c'est toujours ce déménagement ou
le fait de vouloir faire un centre
d'entraînement plus performants et
l'anecdote au tour de francis graille
qui rencontre les propriétaires de
cazaux d'or et qui leur dit moi je
rachèterai bien votre établissement et
l'idée qu'ils étaient sous jacente
s'était creusé un tunnel entre les
terrains actuels d'entraînement du paris
saint germain est le cadeau dehors pour
que les joueurs puissent passer ce je
trouve que c'est à la fois une anecdote
qui était déjà totalement inconnu et
puis ça a un côté un peu de démesure
aussi voilà et ça résume assez bien
l'histoire du paris saint germain au
camp des loges
la voulez vous l'avez dit c'est le maire
de saint germain en laye arnaud péricard
un petit peu qui vous orienter sur ce
livret voulait marquer les 50 ans du
site l'histoire du psg le psg qui va
quitter les travaux ont débuté du côté
de poissy ce camp d'entraînement a
complètement les féminines vont rester
onze matches onze de jeunes aussi c'est
une page qui se tourne mais là c'est une
page qui se tourne une page très
importante de l'histoire du club parce
que le camp des loges dans l'histoire du
paris saint germain c'est le pilier du
club avec le parc des princes évidemment
les mêmes peut-être encore un pilier un
peu plus anciens puisque le club a tout
de suite dès qu'il a été créé en 1977
entraîné tout de suite à saint germain
au camp des loges alors que le paris les
princes était encore en travaux et donc
les premiers matches du paris saint
germain n'ont pas eu lieu au parc des
princes succès en saxe est vraiment un
lieu mythique c'est un lieu mythique
aussi pour le sport en général les bleus
de michel platini ont fait leur rôle
leur mise au vert là pendant quelques
années la rfa est venue lors de l'euro
84 en france ces journées pour paul pour
paul pour moi et puis il ya des grands
champions qui sont passés dans d'autres
disciplines
oui et puis tout ce petit monde ça peut
rencontrer ça fait vivre le site le lieu
la ville alentours aussi ça rayonne au
delà c'est pas non plus complètement
fermées en tout cas celle les terres le
monde un café salé à l'époque dans les
années 80-90 plusieurs sportifs
extrafoot ils publieront omnisports et
qui j'ai pu discuter m'ont dit mais
c'était très sympa on pouvait aller voir
peyroche on pouvait voir luis fernandez
s'entraîner d'autres vous vous racontent
leurs souvenirs quand il venait voir le
psg canali à l'époque on pouvait
raccompagné après avoir suivi
l'entraînement les joueurs jusqu'au
jusqu'au vestiaire donc certains ont en
mémoire d'avoir pu faire un bout de
chemin avec david ginola georges moya
qui était rail qui étaient des stars mot
quasiment du niveau à l'époque de 2 mp
ou neymar aujourd'hui si on regarde la
couverture qui est juste derrière nous
de ce livre
le choix des personnalités vous avez mis
en avant ce c'est l'éditeur
rougeau a asséné mamac cinémas bars ne
peut pas tout sera t on voit pas les
voit même map mêmes maps est champion du
monde français de la région parisienne
donc je pense que c'est un choix aussi
un petit peu éditoriale et puis et puis
kimbembe qui est un enfant du club formé
champion du monde aussi qui est car pour
le coup un véritable attachement au site
voilà et puis après tout d'autres
personnages
meetic est déjà bien sûr non et puis
c'est ce bleu ce bleu bleu et rouge
paris saint-germain aussi qui est mis en
avant
si on reste sur le psg quel regard vous
portez sur le club aujourd'hui et plus
particulièrement sur l'actu la plus
récente sur la saison difficile un petit
peu du psg actuellement en tant que
journaliste sportif si ça se trouve à
dire que ça s'explique un petit peu il
ya des dissensions en interne assez
marquées entre leonardo et tout seul
l'effectif on peut le prendre dans tous
les sens
hormis navas kimbembe marquinhos en
défense et puis les deux stars devant
c'est quand même appauvri mme je trouve
depuis quelques saisons notamment au
milieu de terrain quand vous perdez
rabiot motta même l'hôtel soho
matuidi bah voilà il est moins fort et
puis toute la problématique et coville à
l'arrêt de la saison dernière les
joueurs sont sont pas en grande forme
physique ça se ressent il on est obligé
de d'enchaîner s'arrêtait 4 5 mois dans
une carrière de footballeur ça n'arrête
jamais sauf si vous êtes blessé
gravement et après enchaîné quasiment
deux saisons où une fin de saison avec
une autre donc tout peut s'expliquer la
saison va être tronqué quoi qu'il arrive
et va être difficile dit que des
champions c'est pas la peine d'y penser
à votre avis à l'isaf dans la ligue 1 ça
va ça va le faire
ça reste serré plus longtemps qu'on
pouvait l'imaginer mais ça ça va le
faire si le paris saint germain n'est
pas champion avec neymar mba paix dans
son effectif c'est un cataclysme il faut
pas se mentir en ligue des champions ça
sera ça sera difficile mais on sait
jamais il peut y avoir un retour de
flamme dans la seconde partie de saison
avec une amélioration d'état physique de
l'effectif
merci beaucoup merci à nantes votre
ouvrage être dans l'histoire du camp des
loges donc c'est aux éditions braquage
de sport ont parlé un petit peu des
anecdotes et témoignages aussi on n'a
pas évoqué les différentes photos aussi
parce que le livre et érigeant en
photographie je les montre la très
rapidement ce sont des photos que vous
avez piocher dans aussi vos archives
comment vous avez travaillé l'ouest de
caen a pu récupérer à droite à gauche
que les gens ont eu la gentillesse de
nous donner puis d'autres que l'on
l'éditeur a été obligé d'acheter
évidemment mais voilà c'est un livre
c'est un beau livre je trouve qu en a
peu dans l'édition appelle ça un beau
livre parce que c'est le papier il ya
des qualités il ya 2
la couverture cartonnée et puis il ya
beaucoup de photos voilà une idée de
cadeau pour les fêtes avait forcément
voilà édition braquage record dans
l'histoire du camp des loges merci
beaucoup d'être merci à vous pour cette
émission et on se retrouve très vite
pour un prochain vas y tu es
[Musique]